about 400 of china's most powerful
officials are meeting this week in
beijing
the secretive gathering known as the
plenum is the most important in the
country's political calendar and lays
the groundwork for the coming year
but this week's event is especially
significant
a historical resolution is due to be
unveiled this will determine the
direction of chinese politics both
philosophical and practical for years to
come it's this integration between
philosophy history and politics i think
that makes it unique and this i think is
really focusing global attention on this
new paradigm this
new
way of governing that could lead to real
breakthroughs for humanity
only three official historical
resolutions have been announced since
the chinese communist party was founded
in 1945 party founder mao zedong used
the first to claim his position as
china's absolute leader as well as point
out the missteps of early communist
revolutionaries
in 1981 a resolution announced under
deng xiaoping criticized the problems of
the cultural revolution and justified
economic and industrial reforms
this year the party will mark the
achievements of the past 100 years
it will focus on strengthening the
communist party as the only political
force in china and consolidating xi's
position as the ultimate people's leader
she's positioned in the party is now
unchallenged this is thanks to the
constant purchase during the past nine
years anti-corruption campaigns and
increasing purchase of civil society
public opinion and the internet
in 2018 beijing scrapped presidential
term limits allowing xi to rule for life
earlier this year as the communist party
celebrated a century in rule he declared
the achievement of a moderately
prosperous society
state media touted his success in
following through on promises to make
china wealthy and powerful president xi
jinping is expected to use this year's
plenum to elevate himself above previous
leaders it's likely that his version of
recent history will be accepted as the
official history of the party and he
will further strengthen his power base
but critics say there's great danger in
this
we are seeing a resurgence of
authoritarianism
one that combines the soviet ideology
nazi germany and even previous japanese
and italian models
along with china's own traditions
this means that in face of criticism
from all over the world it is very
difficult for it to react flexibly to
react with a real openness this
seclusion i believe it is the greatest
threat to the chinese communist system
now
the four-day gathering will also include
discussions on who will replace other
top leaders including the premier
starting next year
katrina u al jazeera beijing